okay so this is our Anil gun tooth you
don't look happy
you are yawns bolden oh if you let you
do your whole little intro thing
oh hey that's all I had oh you just
looked so like you know just yeah do it
I don't care why should my feet were
like actually up in the next position
it's just like kind of companies okay so
we are wearing our bracelets from last
time both times that we did it which I'm
sure went over great as you know we do
these all together how would you want
that like all the comments are nothing
like they're all give you this is the
worst thing you've ever done X 10 will
do it standing upside down your noses
oh no no I'm kidding or are we
yeah we're kidding or are so this is
random Gunter's which is first of all I
love the I love the prelude that was in
that the dream episode because we saw
the do we the giant army of go to
reserve formed and I really wanted to
see that again and again it's like they
ain't no but the fans watch those great
writers um and this is an episode where
I tell a couple things come back Ice
King is he's looking for this medallion
right the magic wishing he had the magic
wishing where evil wishing i if the evil
wishing i he can't find in these yelling
at good races don't break anything so he
so he flies off and good dirt goes he
starts breaking all the bottles cuz he's
so mad at Ice King you know can you put
him to the corner and stuff uh holy
slides to the corner stand in the corner
and he's just like just as easily just
one little tear goes down and so he
starts bringing on the bottles and then
he gets the the magic guy the evil magic
guy and puts it on makes all these other
Gunter's and they go and his child yes
I suppose his child gave birth to it
he gave birth or she no that's the sheet
right doesn't matter I come like BMO's
dentures come true
I actually that's we're talking about in
the last episode how they try to go back
and most likely fix problems so when I
love this running joke now that there's
a million counters Gunter's gotten
cancer you know all the different major
looks like that that's brilliant cuz you
know people are like was it good or go
to now you know it's like oh wow that's
really totally made sense but I'm sure
they just made that up later
oh that's still very smart so they
something always said very fart maybe I
did will go back and fix it we'll go
back in say know what but of course it
made sense because in season three of
our view odds
um by oh no in ignition points farting
into the bag exactly so you are very
fart yeah makes sense to me so they go
and they start taking over everything
they just want smash everybody's bottles
and it's sort of that and taking over I
guess I don't know they seem to just be
grabbing people and holding them down
and beating them and stuff so and then
his son daughter whatever goes Kitty it
goes its first leg up the place is
already played for hearing their little
son family that's great um and so they a
lot of weak things after those are
pretty funny talked about his plan to be
mysterious
Jake is reading that he says is actually
not a book of good advice but he listens
to it or he reads it because it's funny
yeah um I think it's very much sort of
like the Fox News Gwen back of blocks
probably like yeah we know it's bad but
it's just fun to listen to
oh yeah oh it's Clint back still on is
that good why would I listen to that I
confused image John handy because it's
hilarious good fox news is the greatest
comedy channel without realizing it's a
comedy channel it's hilarious you gotta
check it out one of these
that come with the show so they put all
these bottles together and they destroy
them all and then they have the plan to
put them all back together so they'll
destroy him again to this obvious thing
is that gonna work so the Ice King comes
back from this meeting of these other
past wizards we've seen before and
there's secret wizard group they
stumbled upon somehow he gets out alive
he doesn't even really talk about how
and he stops Gunter and by giving him
the squirty squirty squirts and that's
about it
it's sort of a big it's a big silly
goofy episode that brings up a lot of
stuff from the past and I don't know it
looks like stuff that's gonna come in
later cuz there's like this was wizard
Huntress was that the name oh yeah she
seemed way too well designed just for a
side character that looks like swing at
every ball but Finn said that not her or
did she know that's what the Ice King
said oh no that's right and it's the
book that then he get it from the book
that I was reading so now I'm curious
who this author but yeah no I I just saw
that character I'm like what she got
doing this episode and she started
disappear so I'm like she looked way too
interesting just to disappear so she
tell me she comes back yeah I don't know
but it's I'm betting she comes back it's
whatever the next season bring her back
go to the forest where people are
pitching and bring her back whatever so
yeah nice it was fine it was crazy it
was a pretty massive size-12 I mean like
they're taking down the giant gumball
guardian's yeah guardians and there's an
army of gooders which is why I love when
they get together and they form the
giant go to I mean I love it whenever
they do that that just cracks me up
um so yeah I thought was fun I thought
was a really fun goofy episode I loved
when they go to Finn and Jake's and
they're like oh we got penguins nothing
briefly have their faces some of my Finn
faces some have Jake faces and so I
briefly yeah
mr. beating each other up oh then good
ride she comes in with his you know
child attached to his back
knocks over the bottles and leaves and
of course comes like oh okay I'll then
of course they find out it's going on
everywhere so it gets up Jake and
they're running he's like wait I'm still
my PJs yeah I love how the Peebles has
her own plan which sell all bad play
sounds bunk and I love that you know
Jake Finn's our Jake says that Finn has
his and then people's comes up with the
third one and Jake's like this plan is
bunk she's like I know when you get in
that situation what the hell are you
gonna do you're yeah I love how none of
I mean these are people that done like
this your own stuff and not armies of
people as if they all have terrible
ideas this dialing yo it's usually like
somebody has a bad idea and then
somebody has a good wonder somebody has
a good one then somebody has a dumb one
but then the good one works it's
something but like everybody had a bad
idea okay it comes from the people that
usually have good ideas so I I thought
that was pretty funny I thought that was
it was just the ice get just get it back
and just give them back the magic evil
eye that's for whatever reason he has to
follow the Ice King it makes me think of
Naruto the arquette okay I'll say it
when we leave the house for an extended
period of time
he doesn't like mess up the house or
anything but in the beginning like he
would kind of go a little bonkers and
like well though he's pissed off at us
cuz he'll poop right next to the litter
box
now then the litter box right next to it
and we know he's pees and just be like
oh how did that happen
I'm a cat oops what are you gonna do I
think that's kind of what almost this
episode was looks like anyone with a pet
knows that when you leave and you come
back that pets a little pissed off at
you
yeah there is there's definitely
something about light wases don't break
anything and he just sort of goes Easter
breakin snow um I mean yeah there is
something just very I don't know it's
like pets will definitely act out
whether or not the happy oh yeah or
whether they want a attention or
something like that so yeah I know if we
got I got that crunchiest I don't even
know where Posey is right now he's
bright breaking the bottles possibly but
he does that a lot or I shouldn't say a
lot he's calmed down now but now he just
interrupts our shots yes at this time
around yeah but everything was you being
attracted by him that's true I'm some
the next episode by the way big episode
big yeah this is like a big big episode
oh the everything burrito game we say in
the next episode
no we're gonna play this for the next
episode right oh yes
so stay around and watch for that hey if
you happen the episodes it just big
because we're playing this game okay so
what the next one called
I remember you yeah nobody makes it
happen in that one see ya I mean is
there anything else gonna say about the
episode
I love Gunther I mean that's for me we
all love counter and his child that's
true
I hope they live very happily together
actually for a comment section if you
know the name of gum tears child please
tell me no I'm sure you'll get only one
response thank you one person who tells
us I'm gonna dubbed that cat milkshake
and if anyone knows that reference that
I'm bringing up I'll blow you a kiss or
something next feel ugh Empire Strikes
Back
alright yes this time I'm walking away
yeah go go to your cat your cat
milkshake